Occidente eligió dormirse
en el preciso momento en que China y la India,
junto al resto de Asia, se despertaron.
¿Por qué ocurrió esto?
Estoy aquí para descifrar este gran misterio.
¿Qué quiero decir con que Occidente eligió dormirse?
Me refiero a la incapacidad de Occidente
de reaccionar de manera inteligente y consciente
ante un nuevo escenario mundial que obviamente ha sido creado
por el retorno de Asia.
Como amigo de Occidente, me angustia esta situación,
entonces mi objetivo hoy es intentar ayudar a Occidente.
Pero tengo que empezar la historia
explicando cómo Occidente despertó al resto del mundo.
Fíjense en el primer gráfico.
Desde el año 1 hasta el año 1820,
las dos economías más grandes del mundo siempre fueron las de China y de la India.
La economía de Europa floreció recién en los últimos 200 años,
seguida por la de Norteamérica.
Entonces, los últimos 200 años de la historia mundial
han sido una gran aberración histórica.
Todas las aberraciones llegan a un fin natural
y esto es lo que se observa.
Si se fijan en el segundo gráfico,
podrán ver la rapidez y la fuerza
con las que están creciendo China y la India.
La pregunta principal es:
¿quién despertó a China y a la India?
La única respuesta honesta a esta pregunta
es que la civilización occidental lo hizo.
Bien sabemos que Occidente fue el primero que logró modernizarse, transformarse.
Al principio utilizó su poder para colonizar y dominar al mundo.
Pero, con el tiempo, compartió el don de la sabiduría occidental
con el resto del mundo.
Me gustaría añadir que, en lo personal, me he beneficiado
de la difusión de la sabiduría occidental.
Al nacer en Singapur,
por entonces una colonia británica pobre,
en 1948,
viví, al igual que tres cuartas partes de la humanidad,
en la pobreza extrema.
De hecho, en mi primer día de escuela, a la edad de seis años,
me inscribieron en un programa de alimentación
porque, técnicamente, estaba desnutrido.
Ahora no hay duda de que estoy sobrealimentado.
(Risas)
Pero el mayor beneficio que recibí fue la educación occidental.
Dado que he recorrido este camino
desde la pobreza del tercer mundo a una vida cómoda de clase media,
puedo hablar con gran convicción del impacto de la sabiduría occidental
y la difusión de la sabiduría occidental en el resto del mundo.
Un don particular que Occidente compartió
fue el arte del razonamiento.
El razonamiento no fue inventado por Occidente.
Es inherente a todas las culturas y civilizaciones.
Amartya Sen describió lo arraigado que está en la civilización india.
Pero, además, no cabe duda
de que fue Occidente el que desarrolló enormemente el arte del razonamiento.
Durante la Revolución Científica,
la Ilustración,
la Revolución Industrial,
Occidente lo desarrolló de manera poderosa
y, lo que es igual de importante, lo utilizó,
lo aplicó para resolver grandes problemas prácticos.
Después, Occidente compartió el arte del razonamiento aplicado
con el resto del mundo,
y puedo decirles que dio paso
a lo que llamo "tres revoluciones silenciosas".
Como asiático,
les diré cómo estas revoluciones silenciosas transformaron Asia.
La primera revolución se produjo en la economía.
La razón principal por la que tantas economías asiáticas,
incluso las sociedades comunistas de China y de Vietnam,
han logrado un desarrollo económico tan espectacular,
es que por fin entendieron, adoptaron y están implementando
una economía de libre mercado,
que es un legado de Occidente.
Adam Smith tenía razón.
Si dejamos que los mercados decidan,
aumenta la productividad.
El segundo legado fue psicológico.
También en este caso hablaré por experiencia propia.
De niño,
mi madre y su generación creían
que la vida estaba determinada por el destino.
No se podía cambiar.
Mi generación
y la generación de asiáticos que me siguió,
creen que no podemos hacernos cargo y mejorar nuestra vida.
Esto puede explicar, por ejemplo,
el auge del espíritu emprendedor que está presente hoy en toda Asia.
Si viajan por Asia hoy en día,
también notarán los efectos de la tercera revolución:
la revolución de la buena gobernanza.
Como resultado de la buena gobernanza,
verán que en Asia hay una mejor atención médica,
una mejor educación,
una mejor infraestructura,
mejores políticas públicas.
Es un mundo diferente.
Después de haber transformado el mundo
con la difusión de la sabiduría occidental en todo el mundo,
la respuesta lógica y racional de Occidente debería haber sido:
"Tenemos que adaptarnos a este nuevo mundo".
Sin embargo, Occidente eligió dormirse.
¿Por qué ocurrió?
Creo que sucedió
porque Occidente se distrajo con dos eventos importantes.
El primer evento fue el final de la Guerra Fría.
Sí, el final de la Guerra Fría fue una gran victoria.
Occidente derrotó a la poderosa Unión Soviética sin hacer un solo disparo.
Qué increíble.
Pero una victoria de tal magnitud
también lleva a la arrogancia y a la soberbia.
Y esta soberbia quedó muy bien plasmada en un famoso ensayo
de Francis Fukuyama
que se llama "El fin de la Historia".
Fukuyama transmitía un mensaje muy sofisticado,
pero lo único que Occidente rescató de ese ensayo
fue que nosotros, las democracias liberales,
hemos triunfado,
no tenemos que cambiar,
no tenemos que adaptarnos,
y es el resto del mundo quien debe cambiar y adaptarse.
Desgraciadamente, como un peligroso opiáceo,
este ensayo le hizo mucho daño al cerebro de Occidente
porque lo hizo dormir
en el preciso momento en que China e India se despertaban,
y Occidente no se adaptó a la situación.
El segundo evento importante fue el 11-S,
que sucedió en 2001.
Como ya sabemos, el 11-S causó gran conmoción y dolor.
Viví personalmente esa conmoción y ese dolor
porque estaba en Manhattan cuando ocurrió el 11-S.
El 11-S también enfureció a mucha gente,
y esa furia llevó a EE. UU. a invadir Afganistán
y más tarde, Irak.
Por desgracia,
en parte como resultado de esta furia,
Occidente no tomó en cuenta la importancia de otro evento
que también ocurrió en 2001.
China se unió a la Organización Mundial del Comercio.
Ahora bien, cuando se incorporan de repente
900 millones de nuevos trabajadores
al sistema capitalista mundial,
llevaría de manera natural
a lo que el economista Joseph Schumpeter llamó la "destrucción creativa".
Los trabajadores occidentales perdieron sus empleos,
se estancaron sus ingresos,
la gente tenía que pensar en nuevas políticas competitivas,
los trabajadores debían volver a capacitarse,
pues necesitaban nuevas habilidades.
Nada de esto se hizo.
En parte, como resultado de esto,
los Estados Unidos se convirtieron
en la única gran sociedad desarrollada
donde el ingreso medio del 50 % de la población más pobre,
sí, el 50 %,
disminuyó en un período de 30 años,
desde 1980 hasta 2010.
Entonces, en parte, el resultado de esto
condujo finalmente al nombramiento de Donald Trump en 2016,
quien aprovechó la furia de la clase trabajadora,
compuesta, en su mayoría, de gente blanca.
También contribuyó al aumento del populismo en Europa.
Y uno se pregunta:
¿podría haberse evitado este populismo
si Occidente no se hubiera distraído
por el final de la Guerra Fría y por el 11-S?
Pero la pregunta principal que enfrentamos hoy es la siguiente:
¿es demasiado tarde?
¿Occidente lo ha perdido todo?
Mi respuesta es que no es demasiado tarde.
Occidente tiene la posibilidad de recuperarse
y fortalecerse.
Utilizando el arte del razonamiento occidental,
recomendaría a Occidente adoptar una nueva estrategia de "las tres M":
minimalista, multilateral y maquiavélica.
(Risas)
¿Por qué minimalista?
A pesar de que se ha acabado el dominio occidental,
Occidente continúa interviniendo e interfiriendo
en los asuntos de muchos países.
Esto es insensato.
Esto genera ira y resentimiento,
especialmente en las sociedades islámicas.
Además, agota los recursos y el espíritu de las sociedades occidentales.
Sé bien que el mundo islámico
está teniendo dificultades para modernizarse.
Tendrá que encontrar su camino,
pero es más probable que lo logre si se lo deja intentarlo por sí mismo.
Puedo decirlo con cierta convicción porque vengo de una región,
el sudeste asiático,
donde viven casi tantos musulmanes como en los países árabes:
266 millones de musulmanes.
El sudeste asiático
es también uno de los continentes más diversos del planeta,
porque hay 146 millones de cristianos,
149 millones de budistas,
los budistas de Mahayana y de Hinayana,
y también hay millones de taoístas, confucionistas, hindúes,
e incluso comunistas.
Alguna vez conocidos como "los países balcánicos de Asia",
el sudeste asiático de hoy debería ser un enfrentamiento de civilizaciones.
Sin embargo, el sudeste asiático de hoy
es uno de los rincones más pacíficos y prósperos de la Tierra,
con la segunda organización regional y multilateral más exitosa,
la ASEAN, por sus siglas en inglés.
Entonces, queda claro que el minimalismo puede funcionar.
Occidente debería probarlo.
(Risas)
(Aplausos)
Pero también reconozco que el minimalismo no puede resolver todos los problemas.
Hay algunos problemas difíciles que deben abordarse:
Al Qaeda e ISIS
siguen siendo amenazas peligrosas.
Deben ser encontrados y destruidos.
La pregunta es: ¿es sensato que Occidente,
que representa un 12 % de la población mundial,
sí, un 12 %,
luche contra estas amenazas por sí solo,
o que luche junto al otro 88 % de la población mundial?
La respuesta lógica y racional
es que debe unir fuerzas con el otro 88 %.
¿A quién debemos recurrir
si se quiere conseguir el apoyo de la humanidad?
Solo hay un lugar:
las Naciones Unidas.
Fui embajador de la ONU dos veces.
Quizá significa que soy un poco parcial,
pero les aseguro que trabajar con la ONU puede conducir al éxito.
¿Cómo es que la primera guerra de Irak,
librada por el presidente George H. W. Bush, fue un éxito,
pero la segunda guerra de Irak,
librada por su hijo, el presidente George W. Bush,
fue un fracaso?
Una razón fundamental es que Bush padre recurrió a la ONU
para obtener el apoyo de la comunidad internacional
antes de declararle la guerra a Irak.
Entonces, el multilateralismo funciona.
Hay otra razón por la que hay que colaborar con la ONU.
El mundo se está encogiendo.
Estamos convirtiéndonos en una aldea pequeña, interdependiente y global.
Todas las aldeas necesitan ayuntamientos,
y el único ayuntamiento mundial que tenemos,
como dijo Kofi Annan, el fallecido secretario general de la ONU,
es la ONU.
Como analista geopolítico,
sé bien que a menudo se considera ingenuo
trabajar para la ONU.
Permítanme expresar mi punto maquiavélico.
Maquiavelo es un figura que a menudo es ridiculizada en Occidente,
pero el filósofo liberal Isaiah Berlin nos recordó
que el objetivo de Maquiavelo era fomentar la virtud, no el mal.
Entonces, ¿cuál es el argumento de Maquiavelo?
Es el siguiente: ¿cuál es la mejor manera que tiene Occidente
para restringir las nuevas potencias emergentes?
La respuesta es que la mejor manera de restringirlas
es a través de reglas y normas multilaterales,
instituciones multilaterales
y procesos multilaterales.
Me gustaría concluir con un importante mensaje final.
Como viejo amigo de Occidente,
soy muy consciente de lo pesimistas que se han vuelto las sociedades occidentales.
Muchos occidentales no avizoran un gran futuro por delante,
no creen que sus hijos tendrán una mejor vida.
Por favor, no teman al futuro ni al resto del mundo.
Puedo decirles esto con cierta convicción,
porque como hindú y sindhi
siento una conexión cultural directa
con las culturas diversas de la sociedad,
con sociedades que se extienden desde Teherán hasta Tokio.
Más de la mitad de la humanidad vive en esta zona,
y con esta conexión cultural directa,
les puedo decir con gran convicción
que si Occidente elige adoptar una estrategia más sensata
y decide ser minimalista, multilateral y maquiavélica,
el resto del mundo estará dispuesto a trabajar con Occidente.
Entonces la humanidad tiene un gran futuro por delante.
Hagámoslo juntos.
Gracias.
(Aplausos)